Yeah, yeah, you're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought. That's what it is. That's what it is. That's what
it is. The internal structure, as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from
the subject. Well, who's your team? Bro, do you have a, do you have a favorite baseball team?
Well, I do. I am a big baseball fan, um, I like the Washington Nationals, who are terrible this year.
Yeah, um, so yeah, they're just, yeah, so when they traded, when they traded shirts or did everything
just, they did, they, and I don't understand why they did that. They were kind of close to hanging
in there and and but then just decided to rebuild and so traded away all of these great players,
including some that they had extended contracts with for a while, like I see trading Scherzer, even
though he's my favorite. It kind of broke my heart to see him go, um, because he had a free agent
um, season coming up and he was going to be very expensive at an older age, so I get that, but they
get they just traded away some amazing players. Now they have nobody. They're basically like a triple
A team except for Juan Soto. So it's kind of like being a fan of the Pacers a bit, a bit, yeah, or the
Pirates. The Pirates are bad too, right? They are. Although they have a, they have a player that is pretty
exciting, some like six seven short stop, yeah, yeah, yeah. And the Orioles are um doing kind of amazingly
well this year even though they're last place in their division. They're in that really good division
after being terrible for many years, so anyway I did notice that there's one I don't even know the
division but there's one division that seems like like every top to bottom they're above 500.
Yeah, that's that's um that's the Yankees and the Orioles and the Blue Jays, like that whole group.
Yeah, I can't even name any players anymore. I mean I know like Bryce Harper. I used to be super into
baseball when I was in like ninth grade and then I kind of lost. I knew because I played the video
games so I knew every single player, you know, on every team, and now they're all they're all younger
than I am now and I don't know any of them. Yeah, yeah, it's sad. It's a sad moment in one's life when
that happens, when you realize that, yeah, they are all much younger than me, there is no way I can ever
um enter this. LeBron and I are are the same age, like I think he's a month younger than I am, so when
he retires that'll be like, you know, my shot is over. It'll happen for you. That's when you start
liking golf because golf gives you another 10 years of like your heroes can play into their 40s.
Makes right right. If I were a pro I guess I'd be in my prime at 28? Is that usually when people start
winning titles and shit, right? So I'm like something like 28 to what 32 33? Right? Yeah, yeah, that's the
window. I don't feel like I'm in my prime though. I feel like that I've I've gone past my prime.
Athletically at this point I feel like I was around like 22 was like the best year. I think if you're not
a professional athlete that's probably true probably. I think I was probably in my athletic prime in my
early 20s.
But but I think that okay so I guess we're talking about I i i we might be jumping right in the middle
here. Yeah, it really is jumping right in the middle too, but whatever. Um, I I always think that it every
time, so there's the and he does this like three different times in this interview where he says
I'm not talking about actual democracy, I'm talking about the democracy to come, or I'm not talking about
the actual international, I'm talking about an internationalism of of singularities, and I'm always
like but the I'm not and instead is like but they're not either ors, right? Like, and he but he talks about
them consistently as if they are, right, as if and he, I mean, I'm not like
telling Derrida something he didn't know, right? Like, I mean, he says I'm not trying to get rid of
the United Nations and this notion of international and would believe we need to hang on to these sort of
this notion of democracy, but what I'm after is something different, and I'm like but
that whole sort of difference, the whole insistence on pointing to a difference to me is presenting it as if
there's the actual and then there's the conceptual, you know, and the conceptual conditions and there
are different kinds of things so that like it would seem to me and he this is the point he makes
repeatedly which is that the democracy yet to come is here and now, right? It's not an idea, it is
imminent and performatively enacted, and so therefore it is only questions of the actual, it is only
circulates through questions of like how do you reform voter registration, how do you like, you know,
what i mean like those types of questions are not sort of things that others can deal with and set
aside because I'm interested in the conditions of possibility, they are they are the whole thing
yeah well that I agree with, I mean like for example with the the question on Nietzsche's orientation
to democracy that I thought that was a good example of what you were talking about in that, um, you know
he's i i think he's installing like a tone or an approach to the the question of Nietzsche on democracy
where you know the the easy way of thinking, like asking that question is like does Nietzsche attack
democracy or does you know what's you know and maybe a slightly more nuanced version of that is what is
democracy for Nietzsche and then realizing that there's a plurality of of democracies and you know
the the approach that Derrida seems to be installing there is more like what senses of democracy emerge
in Nietzsche's engagement with it that both a um sort of locate a particular democracy as the object
of attack and then also posit another version of democracy the democracy uh yet to come as the as
the point or the perspective of of that attack and this is it's important to me that that example
emerges out of the more general concern about like the way that i can't remember if it was now Derrida
or the interviewer um talk about it as Nietzsche's obsession with how the weaker can become the stronger
that's right and then that creating that that dual relationship where like the weaker is only ever
weaker in relationship with a particular kind of stronger or weaker is always only another kind of
stronger that or another kind of strength so just in introducing that that notion of sense and and
um uh yeah that that sense into the question where it prevents the the totalizing response of well
yes Nietzsche is attacking democracy no he is not attacking democracy this is what gets to count as
democracy in this case that you know that's what he's refusing to close oh and that and i get that like
and that and i get that which is like any critique of democracy that Nietzsche might have offered it has to be
being done in the name of something right like it it has to be like if you say there's a problem with
this structure it's like well the recognition of a problem is always done in the interest of
some other potential possible future formation right so it's so i i get that and and honestly as you
respond as as you were responding i was thinking like maybe i'm taking them the task for being in an
interview because it's an interview right like that and so a treatment that you could imagine the
Derridian treatment in uh like a sort of longer form like inspectors of Marx in that case of the the
democracy uh stuff that that parsing that out works differently and i get i i also really like the point
especially as it comes up at the end which i thought was really important about like the rhythm
of thinking and the connection of thinking to language and language to action and it's like no
no this is an action like we are doing this it's happening you know right here right now uh and that
that's the lesson of differance it's not deferral to some future point it's like no no no right here
right now that's a hugely important one for me which is why i think you can also answer your question
question about the supposed separation between the the actual and the conceptual uh in in the exact
opposite direction is that those quote-unquote practical actual questions are are conceptual
questions hidden in sheep's clothing that you know to ask like what do we do about voter registration
installs without thinking about it a ton of generic concepts that then get smeared across a whole lot of
other things but attending to the the singularity in which a particular set of or conceptual orientations
open up the actual that is like in some ways that commonsensical notion of doing the conceptual
work is far more concrete and practical than is the supposedly yeah concrete question of you know this
or that thing which just hides its conceptuality hides the you know i agree i agree maybe another way
this the stuff on the decision which i used to love right like is really great where you know and he's
really clear it's like i'm not saying i'm against reason and thinking and analysis that one has to do
tons of that stuff it's just at the moment of the decision you know if there is one and that'll be
important in a second but like you know it has to be heterogeneous to that order and that's an example
for me now when i read it now as opposed to 10 years ago when i was like oh that's really great
now i'm like why is the preparatory why is the preparatory analytical work not itself
internal to the decision you know what i'm saying like why why do you not say all of these are
decisions that are getting made all along it's not like there's some long protracted uh preparation
for a heterogeneous moment there are only heterogeneous moments within the analytical conceptual
preparatory quote-unquote so in other words it's not preparatory at all yeah right right wouldn't
difference be imminent to every everything every moment within that yeah like that's why i was
confused like what because he sets up that opposition between sort of just following a system and then the
heterogeneous decision and i was thinking at least ontologically even if you're following a schematic all
the way through like wouldn't there still be difference involved content enough contingency
involved in the articulating of that system where it would still be necessarily like heterogeneous or
aleatory like you wouldn't be able to just follow a structure like perfectly right so even if you are
doing that difference is still imminent to that process because you are performatively producing the
structure that you will have followed so the it's not like this i'm agreeing like it's not like the
structure simply pre-exist and you enter into it right exactly yeah i i think that um you know hearing you
describe it like this i mean i have to say i actually really like the i mean i still really like the
discussion of the decision in this way um for reasons i can describe in a second but i mean i i will say
that in later like more more recent pieces where he talks about this it's it's to me much more explicit
the the kind of role of mechanics techniques right that that are also that inhabit pure um response not
reaction right so i think that becomes much clearer like um in The Animal Therefore That I Am or
uh in in he's he's a lot clearer later it seems to me that there is this kind of you know so whereas in
the decision all of the kind of apparatus that helps you make the decision the data the algorithm
um whatever cause and effect reasoning you have right there is a kind of falling away of all that and
the decision is just this kind of step into the abyss where none of that helps you anymore
um not that it doesn't matter but in that moment it's a cutting away of those things and then but
it's but it's as if it's a different moment than the preparatory moment and then i do i do think that
there are moments when um later where he'll write about similar um processes and and he'll emphasize
more the fact that you actually can never get rid of all those machinic um responses that you have
you know that that's also inside of what would be this more um that's a really cool connection that you
made right there for me with the animal book yeah and so far as it's interesting that there's a way in
which and i can understand the logic of that there's an attempt to save the mechanicity of the animal as
being not simply mechanical but the mechanicity of reason
like that's it's so it's more Heideggerian in that regard right like that Heidegger is like
ah look at the the mechanicity or the you know uh the metaphysical qualities of rationality and
that norm you know the ways in which that works and like that's a bad thing that we sort of want
to get away from but in the context of the animal it's like no no no that mechanicity is not
sheerly mechanicity but i really like how you're thinking it is like to say that the thinking in
that context it's not because animals are better uh and the mechanicity is better in animals because
it's somehow organic but it's more just saying like at this moment at this historical moment he's
problematizing a certain function of rationality and at this moment he's problematizing a certain
function of the problematizing of rationality yeah like yeah which actually starts i mean that's that's
the whole like to me that's the really cool beginning for me i really liked the beginning
this time more than i have in the past because he's like you know we don't need to save
Nietzsche like Heidegger attempted to do and he's like and and the reason why not is because i'm not
writing between two world wars right like like that's it it's that simple it's like i'm writing at
a moment and and it just gives you that sense of and of course it's true and we all realize it but
that we're historically embedded in the things that we're responding to like the problem of saving
Heidegger or the problem of saving Nietzsche which was Heidegger's problem for all kinds of totally
understandable reasons it's just not Derrida's problem right like that's just not the the nexus
which were engaged in readings of Nietzsche anymore so that is something i want to talk about is sort
of the the the linkages that attach the stuff in the the first half of of the essay or the of the
interview about Heidegger and his relationship to Nietzsche and Derrida's relationship to Heidegger
and then the the seemingly abrupt transition to the question of decision which is what we're mostly
focused on here but before we go in that direction further i just kind of wanted to set up like part
of what drew us to the one of the major dynamics that we're focusing on here vis-a-vis the decision
is a certain kind of tension between the desire to make choices or to create or to um to create the
conditions of possibility for a future that are not simply mechanically determined, and I I think, I mean
Brooke, that's what has drawn you to it because your your current research project is sort of focused
on, um, on the one hand a discourse, uh, and ethics of of betting and gambling and its linkage to
a more political technological political regime of of reading and interpreting big data and then making
high-level decisions about things like pandemics and and gun loss and and, um, and that the generally the
the central tension between following out mechanically fascistically a a system or a protocol and then the
capacity to actually make decisions that are either within that heterogeneous to it whatever, but I mean I think
this would be if you're open to it just a good time for you to sort of talk through your investment in
that. Yeah, yeah, thanks. What's that? Cool. How how Nathaniel would like took on the role of his host he's
like, yeah, I mean that was a really great moment, like it was even the very beginning of your comment
like let me set the stage and then invite Brooke in like no that was great well it wasn't until you
interrupt it that's just what I was going to say it was so seamless it was so seamless. Um, well thank you
for that, uh, artful segue, Nathaniel. Thanks for having me on the show. First time cold or long time?
Open seat on the show and and and it is true I am kind of interested in this idea of wagering
and and and I think I got interested in it in relation to reading Derrida on the decision or the two, um
the two like the practice of the thought of it and and thinking about it with Derrida on the decision
seemed very, um, powerful to me and and it has for a long time although I think recently kind of post
pandemic, um, you know, 2022 where we are now at in lots of areas of culture from from these kind of
important political things that that you mentioned like gun laws how do we how do we manage life in in
the pandemic era, um, but also much more like from from baseball like sports analytics, um, I I really I
totally I really feel like we're at this moment where, um, our our, you know, life is more and more organized
around, um, using data to manage these small decisions and at at more and more points we are given
information to make better decisions, you know, um, and to think about our individual circumstance against the
backdrop of this huge data set that really can give us some some kind of probabilities that that could help
us decide how to make the wise choice, um, so much so that it that I do think it seems quite mechanistic
and, um, what was the example that you gave in your talk was such a great example? It was the pitcher
uh, that was pulled after the seventh inning in the World Series, right? Right. Could you could you say that
one again because I just remember I remember hearing about it in the sports world and then when you gave
your talk I was like oh that's such a perfect example of the problem, right? Right. So, um, there is this you
know so so baseball is is maybe the sport that is was earliest to come to Moneyball or sabermetrics and
there was this analytic that said by the time pitchers get the third time through the order
their efficiency begins to fall off and that's because the batter the third time through has gotten
a better look, um, has a better sense of how to respond to the pitches that come and so it is the
case, you know, the data does show that the third time through the order batters do better against the
same pitcher so the effect that this is having is that it is really phasing out the starting pitcher like
the starting pitcher is is a dinosaur, you know, not only do they no longer go nine innings like they
used to when I was, um, young, right? Right. So, um, and if you look there was in fact just this week or last
week, uh, Jeff Passan did this story where he looked at the the way this has trickled down no minor league
players go more than like three to five innings so in in 10 years there's not going I mean we'll just have
all mid relievers, you know, like all three three innings at a time which is very I mean not why we watch
baseball, right? But this particular example was, um, I guess it was was it 2020? The 2020 World Series it
was the Tampa Bay Rays against, um, the Dodgers. The Dodgers would win that World Series but the Rays were
like, um, putting up a fight, right? They had a lead in this game and their pitcher Blake Snell was
you know, like killing it. He was, you know, they could not hit him and he he was at something like 75
pitches so not even near that 100 pitch mark that kind of tends to be the cutoff these days for when
fatigue sets in and they begin to worry but he was approaching that third time through the order and
the manager came and took him out and put in the mid reliever who over the course of the season had
had good numbers, you know, like on paper it seemed like a good choice to make, um, but recently that mid
reliever had been struggling and like people were hitting him like crazy and so he he took out this
um, you know, this amazing starter having like the best game of his life put in this struggling
mid reliever and and they just they hit him right away, you know, and he had a wild pitch and then they
um, the the Dodgers came back and won the game and everybody was kind of pointing to this moment like
you had a chance and this was the decisive moment that that blew it for you and the the comment that he
made after Kevin Cash the manager was like yeah i regret what happened but i i don't regret
the decision because i made i made the right decision it just didn't go right, you know, and
and it's it's that thinking of the decision to me that um
that's not what a decision is right like yes you followed what the protocol would suggest what this
did what the what the kind of sabermetrics tell you to do you you you type numbers into a machine
and you did what those numbers told you to do but it strikes me as that like that thinking that he
articulated in that post-game comment it's not just for that one baseball game it's like this is how we're
being encouraged to live our lives now um, you know, like take a look at your covet but it's like what
what's missing from the equation if we call all those analytics like the equation is a variable called
the aleatory right and yeah so yeah this this is the question is like it's not simply about chipping
away from the aleatory and taking things that we used to call aleatory and now making them into
equation it's saying the aleatory is an internal dimension or needs to be thought as an internal
dimension of the equation we usually call that you know we call it in the case of sports we like
you know the eye test or shit like that right it's like the numbers all say this but the eye test says
says something else but but that's not even a very good way of thinking about it i don't think it's not
it's not like one is opposed to the other it's just sort of like um that the application of the
equation should itself be thought as an eye test which is like when are the moments where it makes
sense to apply rigorous analytics and one of the moments that it doesn't like so it's like there's
almost like a baseline equation for when equations should be used well there's also a way that he wasn't
following the more recent analytics because the trend of that game for instance is that Snell
is killing it so if you just follow inning by inning trends and then like you said that mid relieving
pitcher had been struggling recently so maybe his overall era was solid but his era for the last few
games was high so it's almost like he actually wasn't following the answer that's a different question
right like yeah yeah which algorithm do you follow like exactly like what's the algorithm what's the
algorithm for picking the algorithm right and i would even say like i mean part of what i have been
thinking in in the sort of the um what John was talking about earlier is like what does it even look
like to simply follow the program without inserting the decision as if decisions are of one order and the
following of the program is another another order i think in one sense that's very much the case and
that's exactly what Darida is getting at there is that if you just follow the program then no decision has been
made and if there is a decision then it must be heterogeneous to the following of a program
i just don't i'm not sold on the possibility of programs being simply followed yeah you know even
at the conceptual level and you know like at the beginning of your example brooke you you said you
know um, the the this analytics says by the time you get through the third um, time in the in the order
then efficiency drops off and then you said because the the batters are starting to figure them out and
i see that what follows that because is i mean it makes sense you know i mean like that is a narrative
that explains you know that the statistical phenomenon but it's not what the statistics
show i don't think i don't think the statistics have a because i think you can attach a number of
becauses there and one of the most obvious ones i think is precisely what you said but you know there
there would have to be i think this is what we were just getting at is that yeah there would have to be
two other locations for the decision one is where do you cut that analytic on like what does what
counts within that analytic what's the recency bias what's the um, what's the scope of the thing
how does it apply to certain kind like like i'm sure that i don't know i'm sure there's a discrepancy
between left-handed pitchers and right-handed pitchers or righties against going right against
righties or lefties going against righties whatever else it might be but then i think there's also
another species of of the decision within it even within the the analytic itself the decisions that
are forced to attach one causal link to another because i'm increasingly skeptical skeptical of the
idea that anything simply follows anything else that there can only be i mean i do i don't think you know
That anything can go anything can be attached to anything else in all of the in just as easily as
anything else but I don't I'm also just as skeptical that that, you know, even within the most calculable
of sciences that the real, like, it seems that there's always moments of decisions that that, you know, end up
linking this thing to that way and that's the mechanism by which causal yeah no I totally agree and I I think that
one of the things that is a little um concerning to me about this kind of approach to decision making
that I think we see so clearly in sports but but really has kind of been handed to us individually
just in terms of how we manage safety and risk in our own lives um it it is that and and not only is it
like yes so you're you're totally right the the third time through the order that that the the studies
that they've done the numbers they've crunched to come up with that they they don't say why like and and
and kind of happily they couldn't yeah right like and but that's the thing it's like it it just
and and you know reasonable people could like maybe assume and and you could make guesses that that
you know who knows perhaps they're they're likely right um might be other things as well
but the statistics are like yeah it doesn't matter why just just follow the number like just
yeah yeah and and and it's it's it's almost it's an abdication of responsibility like when he says
yeah I regret didn't work out but I don't regret the decision because I made
the right one weird what a weird response to have it's like I regret that it didn't work out but I
don't regret the decision you're like yeah how as as a as a just as a baseball coach like
wouldn't that mean that you might as well just have a computer work out be the manager yeah
you're gonna you're gonna feast on this one but it's the same thing that happened with Paul George
and Damian Lillard when letter ended the season with that crazy deep shot and and George's response
was like it was a bad shot and obviously it went in so in that sense it was a good shot but like
you know like given that historical moment where he took the shop and where he took the shot and
how George was defending like there's a like in some senses he's right is there as well as like
let make him take the bad shot that's right that's right yeah yeah but another another I I I really
love the oh sorry go ahead I mean yeah it is it's just this it's it's like we're being asked to
advocate responsibility on several different levels like yeah so I regret I regret the outcome but not
the decision because the decision was proper and I don't have to decide why these numbers are
right I'm just gonna trust that they are third time through the order that's you know I'm gonna pull
so and I think that's how we're being asked to kind of manage our lives more and more you know like
here's a bunch of data you just you set your own parameters for risk and you decide um you know are
you gonna go it's so I mean there are several levels that are really interesting to me
of this and and one is the the the point that Nathaniel brought up about the installing of the
reason and and I think that that it doesn't matter why actually does matter like there's a presumption
of the reason for instance here's another explanation for that phenomena which is that most people's arms
get tired yeah right it has nothing to do with being faced for the third time it's just that at that
point their arms get tired but of course there could be exceptions like this guy hasn't done anything with
his arm for several days or what you know like and if if that's your underlying presumption you're going
to have a different understanding of of the analysis but the larger point you're making is one that
I feel like I've ranted about on this on this podcast before where I'm like this is one of my
frustrations working in higher education is that I feel like everybody uses policy as a way of avoiding
taking responsibility for making a decision like well the policy is this it's like but yeah but the
circumstances are not identical to the policy like the task I've always felt like every person in those
situations is given a policy and given a situation how do we make these things fit as opposed to simply
how do we subsume the particular situation under this notion of policy and it's consistently like
consistently and smart caring attentive people that are like they throw up their hands at the existence
of policy because policy means the algorithm or it's the equivalent of that like no in this situation
in x situation we do y it's also why when you had something like the pandemic I had so many of my
colleagues just like what the fuck do I do on the exam that I've assigned next week or how do I deal with
this paper that I've given my students it's like they didn't have a policy and they were waiting and
people were angry at the administration for not already having a policy because and my reaction
To it I got tons of emails from people like colleagues of mine and I'm like, you're the
fucking grown-up make a decision right like that's your job is this unprecedented circumstance that has
arisen so now make a decision but they were not just flummoxed by not having a policy but angry at the
administration for not, you know, having anticipated or at least very very quickly come up with a policy
that would allow them to avoid making any decisions and these are PhD these are very smart people who
like I I don't know if it's that they didn't want to do the wrong thing or they didn't want to be on
the wrong side but it was really I mean I ranted about the the teaching award situation we'll have
to edit this one out too of course but like there's this teaching award situation it's the same kind of
circumstance where everyone agrees that the quantitative teaching evaluations are bad they're
just like on so many levels they're terrible and I was like then let's not use them and people were
like that's crazy that's out of control like that's radical and that's yeah and I'm like oh my fucking
god every one of you recognizes a problem and no one wants to take the responsibility of saying let's do
something different like this thing's bad and no one wants to and that's a consistent so when I mean
that's those are the things to me like I totally I see way more now when I think of it as policy and
not necessarily like data-driven analytics although I understand that in the abstract but when I think
of it in terms of like my institutional life the existence of policy is the ways that people avoid
responsibility for making any kind of decision and they think that's their job but I think this needs
to be the refrain is that there is no such thing of as abnegating responsibility there is no such thing
as avoiding the moment of decision because the throwing up of the hands or saying it's the policy or
saying that's what the analytics told me that is the decision right I mean the instant even if it's
the machine that is being installed it still is being installed in that moment configured that way you
know with all of the various contingencies attached to it but like there is a decision there being made
and you know the the decision to sort of toss the policy out or sort of contort it in different ways to
me is no more radical than the decision to simply follow it this is where okay so this is one of the and
I I kind of get and maybe you guys can help me with this one because the decision if there is one is
the recurring refrain like there may not be a decision you know like I kind of get why he's doing
that just because he always does that with like writing if there is such a thing or you know and I
understand it in those contexts but in this particular context I keep wanting to say all there are
are decisions it's different right how can that be if if decision is the movement of difference then
like that's all there can be is is is decisions or why does he want to hang on to okay so why does
I hang on to that one I think he's pretty clear on several places is because he's talking about it
from the perspective of knowledge right so like because the decision is heterogeneous to the order of
knowledge then one cannot say there are decisions with as a knowledge claim right and you know part of the
one of the more interesting things that I got out of reading at this time was the self-effacing nature
of the decision like as the installation of of a machine whatever it is right the the um the whatever
has been installed is going to then reinterpret the decision that has installed it in within the order
of knowledge and so if the decision itself is heterogeneous to the order of knowledge it's
reinterpretation or resubsub subsub subsumption whatever the word you know the word um it has now
like it's now rendered it as something other than a decision or is rendered it as a decision in accordance
with its own yeah logic right so just that makes sense to me yeah it does I mean I do get that but just
politically the valence would be so much at least for me way more interesting where he to say the exact
opposite thing and it's like yes of course we don't know that there was a decision and there's nothing
but decisions like every preparatory like that's all we're doing is perpetually making these decisions
on microscopic levels right like you know little like am I going to talk now or are you going to
talk now or whatever what I took in terms of his concern there is the relationship of the decision to
responsibility right and what he seems to be forestalling is the capacity to say I made a decision that was in
lying with my responsibility and now therefore I am absolutely right right which I think actually I
think that explanation fits more Brooks example of the manager saying I made the decision I made a
decision the decision was to stick within here and now I am absolved of like I didn't like the outcome
but I am absolved of of the culpability of having that outcome to be real yeah exactly um being realized
And and so I think that has a whole lot to do with it is I mean with the route that you want to go
To say that there are only decisions that links itself to responsibility I think very differently
Wherein then one is never absolved of responsibility right yeah and that's what
I'm scared I wants to say right like oh that's absolutely what he wants to say right and in the
political but just think about the difference there would be politically speaking if no one was ever
resolved of of responsibility or in the language of the paper that we i delivered in our last panel of debt no
one is is absolved of this therefore no one can just throw up their hands and it would make sense to
me to turn to as another historical example given the Heidegger Nazi stuff or just like the Nuremberg
trials and you know like the simply following orders it's like there is no such thing as simply
following orders right they can be the decision to to do that might be then retroactively re-inscribed
within that's right the decision or the the order making or the law making apparatus it's like
yeah you were just following orders but like they were there was a perpetual series of decisions
that allowed you to interpret your actions vis-a-vis rule following uh mechanisms that does not absolve
you of you know one of the effects of of articulating this to yourself might be the feeling of having been
absolved of of responsibility with someone else's decision not mine or Brooke's case it was the
algorithm's decision not mine but that's only from within the perspective of of that machine itself
right it seems like more of a i mean it seems like an ethical distinction rather than an ontological
distinction the way that we're articulating it but it seems like in at least in that moment when he's
talking about like where you could not make a decision you could just follow the the system follow the
algorithm and then just assume the effects of that algorithm algorithm like it seems like ontologically
speaking like you were saying John each of those moments even when you're following would still be
decisions right it's like the distinction between like we brushed up against this with Heidegger
the distinction between ontologically between like good thinking or real true thinking and then
calculative or business-like thinking and I think what we came to in and one of those episodes is like
why are they different kinds or levels of thinking for Heidegger wouldn't they be on that same plane
even if they're qualitatively different or ethically you know divergent like wouldn't they be on the same
plane like necessarily that that's that's where I do think it's important to hook this back to uh
what Nathamna mentioned a while back of the the sort of i don't even know if the right word is ambiguity
of Nietzsche right where like who is Nietzsche what is the truth of Nietzsche what does Nietzsche say
let's just stick with that right like this so like what does Nietzsche say about x what does Nietzsche
say about democracy about techniques about whatever else and Derrida is like
he doesn't say anything uh or he says lots of things that can't simply be reduced to a position
and uh or rather the other way of saying it is what he says is any given proposition can be reactively or
active you know reactive force or active force can take hold and so we that's the the play of forces
that constitutes any given proposition right or any given quote-unquote decision and that's the the
issue then for Nietzsche i mean that's what he says right he says that there are uh i mean that's the
positive thing that you can attribute to Nietzsche is that there are there are no facts there are only
interpretations and and so all you're dealing with like ontologically right like is just the the
variations on reactive force or active force taking hold of you know whatever the whatever the claim
whatever the proposition is and this would be simply an example of like the attempt to absolve oneself of
responsibility would be the example of that reactive force like i am not making a decision i am simply
play playing out the the program um which is not to say that it you couldn't also so let's imagine
like for a second like let's imagine what would be a really interesting way of of um thinking the
coaches response like look no matter what I did um I would have been uh what like um I would i was making
a decision regardless and I made the right decision because what counts as a right decision is is coherence
with pre-existing data with history right let's just say it that way so what counts as a right decision
I mean what we mean by right decision is examining history and acting in accordance with with precedent
probabilistically always probabilistically but you're always going to get it wrong so you can say
like he's making an argument for the importance of exactly what Derrida is saying about all the
preparatory stuff and whatever whatever and the playing but that's where you get back to for me you
Get back to the Derrida, if Derrida wants to say that that moment of decision has to be heterogeneous.
It's like, why does it have to be heterogeneous? Like, why, why can't that moment of decision be just
a playing out of the program, and then the experience might be one of absolving oneself of responsibility?
What, what does it, what the ontological relationship, what does it mean for it to be heterogeneous?
Like, is that of a different order to the order of knowledge? Like, yeah, right, to the order of knowledge?
Right, so so the decision, so the decision cannot be subsumed within the understanding, right, because the
decision itself is a is a cut that cuts a particular order of understanding and installs a new one.
Which is why the decision cut from the understand is that like no this is i know but but i'm saying
How do you like, well, I guess you can't identify it as a decision, so right, you wouldn't, that's why
you don't know if there's a decision, right, you don't even, that's why that yeah, hence the the
repetition of that phrase if there is one because the the the cutting that you could say is linking
two systems together is a faced in both directions, right, it has sort of arisen out of one order installs
another order and is retroactively reinterpreted by both of them, but those are but both of those orders
of knowledge are heterogeneous to the decision to cut itself because let's imagine another scenario let's
imagine this scenario with the baseball coach: you see, he goes, okay, all the data says i should pull him,
but the guy's on fire, so i'm going to leave him in and i'm going to go with my gut. So what i'm doing is
i'm making a decision to not use this algorithm but to use the gut algorithm, and he puts the guy out there for
the gut algorithm, the guy gets shelled and they lose the game, and they go, oh my god, you you know
you didn't, he's like, well, i'm just, it's just a question of which algorithm i'm producing, so it's
not like i intervened in a heterogeneous way, right, at all. I just made a different kind of decision at
that moment using a different using the gut or the eye test algorithm instead of the analytics algorithm
right, which is just another algorithm, right, so it's not like it's not like it's a subjective decision
where suddenly like yeah i just went with i want to be heterogeneous subjectivity, right, i want to be
heterogeneous, so even that is subsumed within it's within a machine, it's just the machine is one of guts
you know, or eye tests or whatever you want to call it, and in that case i do think it's more um it has
the facade of being a little more organic. I mean, literally, right, i went with my gut. Um, and it has
it has a higher risk because that's right, they might have fired, right, like he didn't, i mean, he's an
analytics guy, they've been successful because of analytics, all of these things, um, so there is that
like veneer to to that in that particular example, but but i think for Darada like what what matters
about the decision if there is one, it it is this, um, it's also a denial of that just go with your gut
to try, you know, it's it's not that either, right, it's because um the decision involves a kind of giving
oneself over to the aleatory, to the future, um, right, the the future to like there there is a way that
the future kind of inscribes itself, um, on the in the person who makes the decision and kind of
it takes away your mastery, right, i think that's an important aspect of it, so not even like i don't
want to sound like i wanted him to leave the the pitcher in and go with his gut, like that really
isn't the the point, it's um yeah but it is a kind of like it's a giving oneself over and and in that
moment it's like you're no longer like making the decision in this confident um, you know, way that
you won't regret, right, it's a kind of um open they're always gonna you're either always gonna
regret or you're never, i mean, that's the other the flip side of this is there's a way of saying
you know how i feel about the gut. I gave that talk of like don't trust your gut, right, like the
gut is itself or the way of saying that is the gut is itself a machine, it's an algorithm that
constitutes itself, so i mean we call it intuition or we call it whatever, but it's still a kind of
machine, and that machine is fabricated and made in particular kinds of ways, right, like so it's no
it's no more aleatory to go with your gut than it is to sort of follow the analytics in that case, it's
just a different kind of machine that you're choosing from, but in that sense there's no responsibility
right, because there is i mean there's no in the sense of me having responsibility for a decision
it's not me, it's just you take the formative aspects of it as well, and this is sort of i mean
returning to Brooks original examples both of the baseball game and then also that's bled out into
our everyday life, like what do you do and do i go to the the party, i think this is sort of like the
locality of what you're talking about. Do i go to this party given the statistical, you know, um
Case rate of covid and my you know like and then also you know compounding it by my own health risks
and whatever whatever right like do how do i make this decision here and um at least part of the
tension that you're you're focused on are two orientations of those moments to the future, right?
and and the um uh there's a tension between two notions of futures that machines or programs supposedly
realize futures whereas decisions make futures and the the important i got those probably sound a little
bit too similar to each other but you know the the machine um uh projects a future and then does its
best to realize it within a certain degree of failure or success, that success and failure becomes the
metric by which the future is judged. the decision at least the way that Derrida talks about it here
is that it's a creative act that now opens like it literally creates new parameters for what a future can
be like, which means it can't be realized or not realized and it cannot be as you said there has
to be a giving up of mastery not just because of the aleatory dimension of it but because the
performative act is not simply the extension of my will it is the remaking it is it is the performative
like the subject has been retroactively installed um so there is a responsibility but it's a there's
a responsibility there but it's a very different kind of responsibilities the responsibility is not
am i responsible for the future that has happened and then judged in terms of the morality of that like
that not that kind of responsible but now i am now subject to i like the eye that i have become is now
subject to this future that's a different orientation of of a responsibility um and it makes me want to
reach it makes me want to actually turn to some of the other stuff that you you write on um brooke in
terms of ethos as well is that in many ways you know that the example of of the the manager doing this
it seems this is these aren't just like one we could read this these aren't decisions these are these
are just very upfront you know straightforward uh instances of rhetorical ethos the the algorithm has a
certain kind of authority and i defer to it right there and and that's one way of that's a cool way
of thinking of it by the way to think of ethos of the machine right that the the quantitative analysis
has comes within in other words it's making an argument by its sheer quantitative yes exactly right
which is now i am subject to this thing there isn't there like ethos is the relationship that is
defining me as decision making maker to the to this apparatus but then there's another sense of ethos in
that that second sense of responsibility is that the making of the future here is also simultaneously
the making of a new subjectivity making of a new ethos to this relationship to to that and like that
that dynamic i think is incredibly important and i really want to make this a little bit more non like
extract the human in terms of the conscious you know responsible subject making decision and like i'm
increase again i'm increasingly suspicious of a machine having the capacity to and i mean this in a very
precise way play itself out in a homogeneous kind of way i i don't know what it would be for the algorithm
to simply and i'm uh and this one i'm going to put an asterisk play itself off if we mean play itself
out as in a homogeneous line that links necessarily every line forward as if it were simply an equation
as if there's no alters now i do think algorithms and machines play themselves out all of the time
right and that they do make linkages between things all of the time but there is still an
aleatory heterogeneous relationship there it is never simply the homogeneous um movement of you know the
self-contained identity whatever the core equation is let's call it efficiency whatever that core
equation is of efficiency in its relationship to by the way at effectivity we always love to talk about
efficiency without like what counts as efficiency right that's that other mystery term but um i just
i don't think that there is one way in which that plate that that has to play itself out there is no
homogeneous notion of efficiency that then necessarily plays itself out there are decisions made all of
the time about how efficiency gets articulated and related to this and then re-articulating it
related to this but i don't think are simple human conscious decisions it is sort of like
the decision making of the machine in some kinds of ways
um i mean it is kind of interesting to think about the way you know um i mean and i am interested in
this moment where we are remade in in the moment of the decision and that it is a kind of um
you know the self is is wagered right at every moment um in in the moment of every decision and
always lost yes and and i and i i mean i i don't know the mechanics of these things well enough but
isn't it the case that you know the algorithm is remade when you choose whatever show you choose on
Netflix right like that changes the it's like it is there is a way that it's happening
at this level too it doesn't have to be um it doesn't simply have to be this kind of human
centric re um and we're back at the problem of repetition yeah that's right you know yeah the sort
of empty repetition or you know whatever mechanical reproduction right this is Benjamin right right
you also get the sense but I do think I mean just I mean just to kind of maybe to to tie up this
this thread of the of the conversation I mean I do think that we're at this moment now where we're
much more conscious of being being asked to um wager you know with who we are with our safety with our
you know what I mean it's like it's almost like it's reached this level of I mean experience um yes
but it's not simply a metaphor right like we're not simply like you know like betting our lives but
kind of we're asked to do that all the time right with you know um risk assessment cost benefit
analysis like that's those sort of large amorphous economic terms have become part of our daily
lives when we like we'll fucking walk out the door right yeah every moment even when we're inside our
houses right like that but just think about the way moments that those big data assessments presume and
then also make the individualized subject right is is that you know the where does it locate responsibility
increasingly on the individual where you know this is it's not just risk assessment it's my risk
assessment and my tolerance for my risk tolerance as well and you know it creates a funneling point
where all of the pressure all of the weight of that decision making that's falls on a single person
right yeah yeah so it's it's an atomized amount of response of so i think of it it just to concretize
it a little bit it's like i feel all the time in terms of taking care of my mom's health right
like i feel all the time like I'm just not doing enough research like I'm just I and and I do a fair
amount or whatever but it doesn't matter how much you do it's like I haven't read every article on
Covid exposures I don't know everything about this thing and I'm making decisions partly because I'm
like I don't believe anyone can know all of the research and I'm making a best guess I do you know
like is this a good thing to go to should she go to this event at the church where there's going to be
50 people inside of the you know whatever and and I'm I'm always in this position of like I'm going to
fail I'm going to fail like it's in because I have internalized that sense of like I must I must be
responsible for whatever decision you know and and it so that's the flip side of that sense of the
responsibility falls to the atomized individual though the demand to assume it comes from everything
right like everything out there and when the well in a situation where the stakes are less high like
people invite that kind of quantifying of their whole selfhood into their lives like with fitness
trackers and health trackers and stuff like that where you the the telos or the the trajectory or
system is a success failure operation where like you're told you don't meet these goals and right
you have to get a 10 000 20 000 steps or your heart rate needs to get to this point and people become
obsessed with these analytics or metrics um and i think it generates a lot of anxiety um in the
individual you know generally or self-assured but also motivation too right like i mean it's like
okay I'm gonna get it's changed my dad's house right yeah he's like yeah yeah and for him you know
it's totally like you've been stalling that success failure metric and you're right I do think it
introduces an obsession I would but then I would go back to Brookslam is like it's not just it's not
you're adding obsession onto the prior individual you've made it an individual that is constituted by
by this kind of yeah by obsession with risk risk assessment well and risk is the negative term but
like uh what's a performance optimization yeah yeah it would be the positive way of saying like I'm going
to optimize my this is like the Joe Rogan thing yeah like it I will optimize my life yep um is the flip
side of the risk management which is the sort of negative downside of it but that takes my body
calculation into like what what it does is is it reifies the good and the bad and it moves all of
the mental operation into the logistics of the how how to avoid this how to like or how to create
conditions of possibility where this is realized more the likelihood of this being realized is less
than not being realized whereas the question of the like optimization of what right like I mean that's
those are the questions that are generally left to the wayside yeah but in the end but I think the
answer for the for like the Joe Rogan strand the the answer is always life right like it's life
optimization this is Foucault right like productive power and the generating the powers of life the
Forces of life increasing vitality, right? We want more life, more, more intensely, more. That's the
difference between the will to power and the will to have power, right? Yeah, yeah, I mean, sure, if the if
the optimization is for a pre-established subjectivity, then that is very different than the optimization
of life itself, which very well may necessitate or by happenstance sort of involve the destruction of
that's right of not maybe not just the, you know, ethical, juridical, political subject, but the
biological life of, of the person as well. I mean, what does life care about, you know, the biological
organism that I call me, right? But it is not particularly it doesn't particularly care about
it. Yeah, I mean, the the Joe Rogan in fact my existence might be a problem for the continuance of
life writ large, right? But that that's life as a general category, life as its
instantiation in you, which is to say, like, the the Nathaniel Street version of life has its own
will to power, right? Like, it's, it's its own instant, and we all have them, and then from that
emerges social orders or vice versa, you know? But we also have to like, but I bet again even within that
more like, you know, from life to a life, right? They would still have to be the perpetual upheaval of
you know, this or that version of Nathaniel. Oh, I agree, and there is there is a sense in which I mean
I agree with that, and there is a sense in which like, um, that notion of life optimization is so
a contextual and so non-respective, it's just like, I want to be the best me that I can be
seems like something that I'm supposed to undertake that has nothing to do
you shouldn't advertise with the circumstances of my life, right? Like, it's like I, that's, that's again
another responsibility that falls on me to optimize my life well it creates like false man. I mean, we're
just guilty fucking individuals, like we're always failing, yeah, failing at that. You should love me. The
best thing about me is that I've died, you know, dozens of times, and the more I die, the you know, like the
the better the happier I am in some ways. The the Joe Rogan thing. One last thing on the life
optimization thread is that it it creates because people want answers to whatever if they have a
lot of inflammation they want to find a quick solution to that, and that approach finds answers
like or advertises answers that aren't, you know, necessarily that beneficial for everybody, like it's
like, all right, you have to take an ice bath every day, okay, tomorrow it's actually heat is what like
reduces inflammation. Oh, you want to get rid of depression? Well then psychedelics is the new
thing that's come onto the scene that's going to cure you of anxiety and depression, so it's like
all of the, they're just constantly reaching for the next solution to your problems, and I think it
creates the problem with that isn't the clumsiness of it, right? It's not the clumsiness of it because
you know, like, I don't know, turmeric baths, I'm sure are fantastic for some people and and terrible
for others. I hope hopefully someone hears a thing I don't think it is, but I really hope someone
hears it and turns it into a thing, thinking you have to add a sufficient amount of olive oil so
it. Yeah, with turmeric baths, there we go, that can be our sponsor, yeah, yeah, that's I think we have
the title for this episode, you know, like, I mean, that it's not the clumsiness of it, it's not that it's
going to work for some people and not others and that we're not nuanced enough in it. It is the driver
the desire to alleviate the anxiety by finding the answer by like the problem seems to be the
on a surety of not knowing, which I would take the exact opposite response. It's like the not knowing
is the constituent of of of life, that the knowing part ends up being a self-perpetuating cancer that's
like, I'm narrowing it is again to return, it is the problem of Nazism or the problem of fascism is that
as soon as you've developed the final solution, whatever whatever that's anti-inflammation or
you know, like no more undesirables in the world or anything else, doesn't matter what it is, right?
the the more the uh, the more clearly you articulate that end and the more you move toward it
the more fanatical and the and and the more sort of like rarefied that you know that impulse
becomes the more totalizing, like like everything is subsumed under the desire to realize that um
that that end. Do I always think that fascism is this the ultimate was the ultimate death drive
right? It's like what counts as Arian enough? Certainly not me, certainly no one that's ever lived
right? And he's stressed in the name of life optimization too, in the name of life optimization
right. The death like lifetimes is its own particular brand of of death drive, but and
then Derrida stresses though, and I like this one section because it really resonates with the whole
Hegelian thread that I take up, but where he's he stresses that, you know, our culpability in for
example fascism, racism, that's irreducible so you don't get to buy out of the really bad
shit either. Like, the contamination is the bottom line. You haven't brought up that word. The necessity of
contaminant, but that and that also kind of resolves the responsibility question which is like it's
always, I mean, his direction is different, which is like you never get to feel good about right the
decision, but the flip side would be you never have to feel bad about it either, right? Like it's it's
never simply your responsibility because that's the structure of contamination and that I mean I that
strikes me as that's the Nietzsche lesson, right? That's the whole sort of necessity of interpretation
is the necessary contamination. Nothing is truly either good or bad.
Um, can I, in the kind of spirit of Thinking With, I want to run something by you that I feel is related
to what we've been discussing, and so you know I'm working on this book that's kind of on
you know different rhetorical accounts of gambling and and um Derrida on the decision is part of that, the
wager as as an expression of performative becoming is part of that. I've been thinking about um so you
remember several years ago now the the shooting in Las Vegas, the the um sniper I got the room and and
Mandalay Bay and and and and murdered all of those those people at the concert so he was um
uh like kind of a big time video poker player, was on in their systems high high roller like cycling through
I can't remember the numbers now but a ton of money um on on video poker which is this kind of
game it's it's like so and there is a spectrum of of gambling of of how involved you are in in the
gambling game so something like poker for example you have to make you have to make decisions um and
I mean that as simply as possible at every turn right? Like how much am I going to bet now? Do I believe
what this person is is um suggesting with their behavior so so all of these moments you are kind of
actively making these the decisions just in order to to participate in the in the gambling uh in the in
that game and video poker on the other hand it just becomes this I mean it is it's a there is optimal
play you know if if you get xyz you you dump two you keep three I mean and and there's there's a lot
of research on how fast people just roll through that money they don't even care when they win, right?
Something happens to you if you're addicted to video poker where the win is actually a problem because
it slows down your play like if you've won so much you need to get a hand pay like people don't
actually want to win they just want to like obliterate themselves in this process whereby you are
totally removed like you're really not making any decisions at all you've memorized and it moves so
quickly um and that and that's what this guy was and he he did that um like I was reading he was he
was like morning of every day leading up to it he had he went down to the bar was playing um I think
there was even reporting on how much money you know and it was a lot of money that he was putting and so
he was rolling through a ton of hands you know um dozens maybe hundreds of hands um
a minute I can't I can't I don't know but you can move it really fast you can adjust the speed
and probably playing multiple games at the same time right? Yeah, you can have like six on a screen. I mean
I don't I don't know what the what the setup was but it kind of strikes me that
it's not unrelated I don't know you know it's like that kind of um right? You've you've chosen the
game and and it is it is a kind of capitalistic it's like um it's it's part of this dissociated
experience of being in the casino um where you're really taking yourself out you know um and that's
the person who went up and it's a particular kind of individuation though because as you said it
there's a kind of a self-obliterating like yeah the the act the decision the act of goal seems to be
actively to remove decision making I completely subsume myself to you know a particular right? Like you
you could not do it you could not play but there's there's something about it's like it's almost a game
that you play so you don't have to decide yeah right and in a way that fully automate yourself
yeah yeah yeah in a way that's more that's the goal right? It would be if you weren't playing you'd
have to make other decisions in your life like you you know like should I drink this coffee or not
whatever the coping mechanisms and anxiety yeah my immediate response is like some people cope with
anxiety by finding certainty in the moral righteousness of what they're doing other ones
obliterate responsibility by completely subsuming themselves to the machinery of yeah you know of
the of the game or or the chemical or the hat or the habit like I like every morning I have the same
Smoothie, right? Like, and I don't have, it's so reassuring because I don't want to have to think
about what I'm going to eat, right? Like, I just go through them. Like, I sometimes am, I, I'll get to
the point where I'm actually making the smoothie and I realize I don't remember making the smoothie
right? Like, I don't remember actually putting the stuff in there because it's become so ritualized
and habitualized and it's great. Like, that's one less thing that I have to think about, right? So that
that sense of removing the conscious, removing consciousness, the self as that, yeah, removing the self, it's
it's it's like, um, no, a salve, as in, like, the consciousness is a wound. Decision making
consciousness is a wound. The repetition habit is a salve that alleviates one of that pain.
and and in a in a difficult way, I mean, that's what Derrida's decision is, right? It is a giving yourself
over. You don't get to have a kind of active control over it and yet I think the way that he talks about the
decision it seems to hang on to a kind of um, I guess responsibility is the word I'd want to use
not not like not simple responsibility but but we're talking about this entirely in terms of the
consequences for the person who engages in the practice. What there is not is any thought whatsoever
of anything outside of that loop, right? I mean, that's that's where the Vegas guy is a little bit
different. He's not making a smoothie. He's killing other humans, right? Like, so that's a different kind
of, I mean, there's a there's a consequence to the other in term as in terms of that which is outside
of him. That's just like uh, erased, right? So there's different versions of machinics I think and some of
them integrate otherness or the aleatory or the outside into the system and others close absolutely
close that off because there's a different spirit animating the two as well is the sort of like the
the subject subjecting myself to the machinery of the video game or whatever the habit or whatever else
it is is precisely to alleviate the anxiety to absolve myself of the responsibility and of the of the
the anxiety in particular the kind of like giving self oneself over to the decision that there was
talking about is an anxiety amplifying device. It is not an ownership of anxiety but a a willingness to
become perpetually involved at risk perpetually at risk perpetually involved with precisely it's not
a fleeing from anxiety it's a it's a maybe not a rushing to anxiety no it definitely is like a yeah yeah I
mean I totally agree I totally agree but I but I I guess I just still there I mean there is some sort of
little bit of like playing out the algorithm like that strikes me as a little closer to the video
poker game than right then than this other version that that I think Derrida has. I mean that's where you
say like there's something interesting to this guy's desire right there is I mean there is in terms of a
an interruption of the self as this kind of conscious a conscious agent making choices that it just becomes
it's like I am becoming machine so I want to not have to make decisions and I don't even want to win
right? Like, that's an interesting way. I mean, think of the think of the Deleuze stuff on on the dice throw
right? Like, the bad players are the ones that want to win. These folks don't want to win so these are
these are the good good players in a certain sense, right? That they're just like they just want to play
and disappear into the playing of the game but they don't care about futurity at all. They don't care
right? That's right. There's another component to the machine that is just not present in their uh, in their
circuit. Yeah, it obviously it's not to say that you know one is causally linked or or even reasonably
linked to the other but it just it just seems like it's an interesting side to think in. I mean I know
I agree. Like, that's where to me that's where the Nietzsche stuff is so great. It's like, hey, there is
a reactive way of becoming machinic and there's an active way of becoming machine, you know. There's
it's not simply good or bad and that that the sort of elision of responsibility is not simply good or
bad, right? But I mean the the clearest link that I see between that sort of that particular kind of
coping mechanism of the sort of assumption within the machine is the conviction that it allows for
like even just like you know, the anterior decision made is again saying like I know when I am dealt you
know pocket queens this is what I do and you know the the peace of mind that that provides the conviction
that provides to me is cut from a very similar cloth that I mean like my my reading on you know mass
shootings is is sufficiently limited but like my very vague sense is that like there's a certain kind of
conviction conviction conviction that accompanies mass shootings or or like these kinds of senses of
violence is that this is unquestionably the right thing to do or unquestionably the thing to be done
that that the you know there is no there is no space for alternative I was dealt you know I am looking at
A pair of pocket queens, this is what has to happen well and for Heidegger and for Hegel there's a direct
connection between the comfort of identity and the comfort of assuming a subject position and the violence
that that compels